The one thing I can say
about my journey that
I didn't plan for any of this.
In fact, I was quite resistant
at the beginning.
Arod Balissa, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you for having me.
It's wonderful to have you.
And it's going to be wonderful
to talk about your different
entrepreneurial endeavors.
A lot of them are social,
a lot of them are community.
I think that if I look
at the different things
that you've done along your career,
perhaps besides the legal stuff,
we're looking at
a pretty comprehensive list of activities
that are very much involving
the community, particularly that of
the ecosystem in Israel.
So Arod, tell me a little bit
about your journey,
leading all the way up to being
to managing Deloitte Catalyst
in Israel for startups?
Well, you know, I guess the one thing
I can say about my journey that
I didn't plan for any of this.
in fact, I was quite resistant
at the beginning.
It started, I'd say Wize started about
10 years ago.
I think it was 2011.
And I was just out of the army
after three years at 8200.
And there was this thing,
the Facebook was just starting to share,
to let you tag people in things.
And I remember that
I was very bent on sharing things
with people like TED talks
and stuff like that.
And the thing wouldn't let me
tag more than six people.
So, I created the group
and hope that if we have
about 30, 40 people that I know
and would, you know,
would not block me or unfriend me.
And it kind of took a life of its own.
I'd say, it quickly grew to like
a 500, 700 people group
that was pretty active at the time.
And, you know, I'm not going to walk you
through the entire group history
because it doesn't really matter.
But it was on that venue that
a bunch of us have decided
to create an event for that community.
I think the idea was originally by
the shows friend, Guy Katsovich.
He came to us, he came to me
and few of the people and said,
"Hey, why don't we
have a community event?"
I thought it was a good idea.
You know, we did it.
It was quite successful.
And then I remember one time,
Guy paid me a visit and said,
"Hey, I've got this offer to you
to do this at the bar
let's say every once in two weeks."
And my immediate reaction was,
it was never going to work.
You know, I'm thankful
that he has beg to differ.
But you know,
the thing was that I wasn't really sure
that would work
and that we should do it.
And 10 years later, I can tell you
that I am very happy that I was wrong.
And I think, one of the things that
since then and actually even before that
I have characterize my approach is that,
I try to listen and let myself be wrong.
It's a hard thing to do.
And I know a lot of people, you know,
talk about failures and being wrong.
Here, it wasn't a failure.
I think, generally speaking,
it was a success.
But I was wrong.
I thought that there's no way
it would work and it kind of it did.
Not kind of.
I mean, Wize, over the years
has had hundreds of events
impacting thousands of people.
I mean, it's been a huge success,
to say the least.
Yeah. You know, I completely agree.
And it has transformed
into something that is
a critical part of my identity.
And I'd say that,
but I always whenever I'm asked about it,
I always start with the fact that
I was at the beginning,
I never thought it would work.
And I mean, to this day,
I'm really not sure why it still does
But I think I am, we are fortunate
that it still does
and that people in Israel
are very excited about the things we do
and about the events
and the content we bring.
But, you know, I guess
the first few years of Wize
kind of gave me the confidence
that I needed in order
to do more things or more endeavors.
And I think one of the things
that changed about me the most
is that I kind of realized that
if it won't work, it'll be fine.
I mean, you know,
the term we like to use in Israel
is fail fast, fail often.
And I think part of my,
one of my strategies was
or one of my strategies
till this very day is,
okay, I mean, fine, if it won't work,
it won't work.
We'll just, you know,
pick up the debris and move forward.
And I think it has been the
kind of like a cornerstone
of the way that I approach new things.
And it's not easy.
Emotionally, it's not easy for me.
And I think I'm a relatively
conservative person at nature.
And I keep trying to push myself
into new things because,
you know, because it has proved
that to be a generally good strategy.
Right. So, once we move past Wize.
You've implemented the same mindset
into all the different endeavors
that you've done.
So, talk to me a little bit about them.
And how did you bring
that mindset to develop these?
Again, I think,
so, we did learn a lot at Wize.
All of us.
All the people who were involved
and all the people
who are still involved,
we learned so much.
So much about, anything from operations
and making sure that things run on time,
and all the way up to leadership.
We incorporated a nonprofit,
I'd say in 2012 or something
as a [--], an association.
And, you know, we
when you form an association,
you have to have a board of directors.
But really, when you are
a five to 10 people operation,
it really doesn't matter.
And especially when you are 22 or 23.
I didn't realize what it meant
to be a board member
and it didn't really mean anything
at the time.
But I think as we grew
and as I've spent more time doing,
you know, doing the work
in the first few years
and then kind of transitioning
to leading to managing individuals
and what is now teams,
you know, I think I've learned a lot
in terms of what does it mean to manage,
what does it mean to lead.
And in a way I think that we
kind of grew or at least
the people who are now on the board,
we kind of grew into the role.
And I think that today,
if I think about it,
the thing that was most impactful
is to know how to take a step back
and also bring other people in.
Trust the delegate effectively.
Work with them, in some cases
even mentor them
and really letting other people share
that thing that we've created
about 10 years ago.
Right. So, it's not just the community
that's the customer base
or the people that are using the product
or leveraging the association
and the non-profits work,
but it's also internally
the people that are running it.
And, of course, I'm assuming that
when you were discussing non-profits
and these sorts of associations,
you need the people there to,
first of all, be very in, right?
You need to really lube them in,
you need to really make it a community
primarily because
this is a non-profitable work.
And the motivations
for volunteering their time
at a non-profit work
are very, very different
than being a board member
of a for profit startup, perhaps. \Right?
100%.
I think that in a nonprofit,
you know, the internal motivations
are almost all you have.
I mean, in a for profit organization
or in a startup,
it's always a mix between
the money and the compensation
and the internal motivation,
which is very important.
If you want to have an A-team,
then you definitely need that.
It's just that in a nonprofit,
that's pretty much all you got.
And when you're already dealing
with volunteers, especially.
And I think that the key idea
is to help people find meaning
in their work.
And that's really not easy.
It's not easy for, you know,
it's not easy because
people have different agendas
and they have different
personality structures.
And people need, different people need
different levels of guidance
and different levels of support.
Some people are more independent
and they just want to go for it.
And some people need the guidance.
And I think that
that commitment is something
that can manifest itself
in different ways.
And it never stops.
Let me give you an example
from this day and age.
Corona hits
and, you know, we had to transition
from the bars environment
and the offline environment
to the online environment.
And, you know, as technical as it sounds,
it was also a profound change.
And one of the reasons it's such
a profound change is not because
well, it is because
people consume content online
in that in the bar,
but it really impacted our volunteers.
Because the DNA of our organization
was the physical interaction
with one another in bars.
And it was for our volunteers
and for our staff
as much as it was for our audience.
Now, it took us a while
to understand how
you know, how dramatic the change is
and we are still undergoing a process.
We are trying to redefine
what it means to volunteer at Wize.
Now, to be very honest,
and I think it is you know,
it is crucial to say that while
we as the organization's leadership
kind of had to step back
and think about
what we can do differently
and how we can redefine
the meaning of being
a volunteer at Wize,
it is, it was and it will be
a team effort.
And we need all of our volunteers
and all of our staff
to be committed to this.
And if they're not committed,
then maybe we're doing something wrong
And just to finish the thought, you know,
the key issue in all of this is that,
you know, you make mistakes
you test something in the field,
you make more mistakes,
you try to implement it,
and you basically try to be
honest and transparent enough about it
in order to be successful,
in order to transition well
from one environment to another.
100%.
The impact that Wize has had
is phenomenal.
But you've also taken part
in quite a few other activities
as a board member.
Particularly, both of the
Israel Internet Association,
but even more exciting for me,
the Alumni Association for 8200.
So, talk to me about your activity there
and what lessons have you brought
from Wize to this association
in your learnings?
Well, so, I didn't start off
as a board member.
I started as a newsletter editor.
And I, you know, I volunteered there
and I spent a lot of time
doing that about,
I'd say two or three years.
And I think for this,
it was a very busy time
for me personally
with school and work
and a few other commitments in Wize.
And same thing,
I just decided to go for it
and see if it'll work.
And I just really enjoyed the journey.
And then at some point
where I entered the board of directors,
I'd say that
I did bring a lot of the things
I didn't do well at Wize.
All the things
that didn't really work well for me
or didn't really work well in general
and all of my missteps,
I just tried to learn back from them.
And the alumni association
is a much different organization.
And I love it dearly.
I'm still very much involved
and I keep on wanting
to be more and more involved.
I love the organization.
I think it's a phenomenal platform for,
to make an impact both on our members
and our alumni,
but also on the Israeli society.
And I think that the one of the things
that I kind of brought with me
is trying to learn
how to be a good board member,
which is a very tricky thing to do.
Because as a board member,
often times you have a
kind of like an internal struggle
between being you know,
you want to be there,
you want to get things done,
you want to be active,
but you have to remember
it's not your job.
Your job is,
as a board member, of course,
is to weigh in,
is to be strategic,
to be thoughtful, to help,
to offer help if you can,
and also be a part of the conversation.
I think, one of the things that,
you know, one of the things
that I carry on to this very day
is that, and this is something
that a friend told me,
I think originally came
from Stef Wertheimer
but I don't know him personally.
So, I can't attest.
But a board member does three things.
They appoint a CEO,
they fire a CEO,
and they ask, "How can I help?"
And I think the problem starts
when board members, in general
not necessarily in any organization,
but the problem is,
is where board members act as executives.
That's where usually
where the problem starts.
Now, we didn't have a CEO for a while,
for several years, but now we do.
We have for about
the last year and a half.
And I think that for me personally,
it kind of was an opportunity to test
my ability to be
an effective board member
and to be there
for the CEO and to support
and not to, you know,
want to take charge.
Which is never a good thing.
Wow. That's fascinating.
So, what were some
of your responsibilities
or what was your experience
being a board member that
if you're looking across the board,
for these three organizations,
what key insight do you have
to potentially other board members
that of how they can really
be helpful and non-clashing?
Because this is a topic
that has come
time and time again on this show
of what it means to be a supportive
and helpful board member
versus one that may be
clashing or disruptive to the process.
So, I'd love to hear
one or two key insights
from your experience.
That's an excellent question.
There's a couple of things.
One is, the role of the board
in my mind, is to provide strategic,
strategic guidance to the executives.
It is, and I think that, you know
a board can be too involved
and it could also be too detached
and both things aren't great.
It really takes, it takes a very, very
you know, it takes being very minded
and very thoughtful
in order to create the balance
between being too involved
and too detached.
Right.
I think that there's a conception,
there's a and just I don't know,
a thought there's a conception that
a board needs to do
their work full time.
And maybe in a Fortune 500 company,
they have to be,
you know, doing their job like
as full time gig, maybe. I don't know.
I've never been
in the Fortune 500 board.
But I think that from my experience,
the key issue is
to work with your executives
to strike the right balance.
There's no one answer.
It really depends on what
your executives need.
So, that's one feat.
Striking the right balance between
being too much involved
and not being involved at all.
The second thing is,
as a board member,
not necessarily as a board,
but as a board member,
and this is going to sound very cliche,
but I still think
it's incredibly important.
It's crafting a good
and helpful relationship with the CEO
and with his leadership team.
And the key to crafting
a good relationship
is to show that you're there,
you're active, you're interested,
you're willing to put in the time,
but you're not there
to step on their toes.
At a certain time, you have to be able
to take a step back
and say, "I've said my piece.
I'm not going to get too involved."
And you know, I've done this.
I was wrong about this many times.
I have over kind of stepped
my boundaries as a board member.
I have been too involved
and sometimes I've been too detached.
And to be very honest,
I'm still trying to figure out
what's the correct word, sorry,
what's the correct balance
for each board that I'm in.
And the last thing the last insight,
if you want to call it,
is different boards
have different dynamics.
And to be an effective board member,
you have to be able
to read those dynamics
and take and kind of choose what role
you want to play.
Now, a good friend once told me
that a person needs to know
when they are in charge
and when they are followers.
In the way he said
it was just typical to Israel,
A person needs to know
when he's a commander or a soldier.
Yeah.
And I think it's incredibly important.
Especially for,
it's actually easier for people
who sit on several boards.
But the idea is that, you know,
different boards have different dynamics
and they tend to have
different levels of conversation.
And I think that
you want to decide how active
and in what ways you can be
and what is your role
on that board.
I'll give one example.
In my role in the group dynamic
in the Internet Association
is profoundly different than what it is
in the alumni association,
in the sense that
there are things, for example,
in the organization's activities that I,
I don't have a lot of input.
For example, there's a lot of
technical issues that have to do with,
how do we make sure
that the nation's servers
are kept afloat.
Honestly, nothing.
I have nothing to say about this.
That makes a lot of sense.
And Arod, I really want to thank you
for shining light for me
and for everybody else that's listening
about the responsibilities
of a board member.
And more importantly, the positive ways
to make a positive impact on a board.
And I think that it's
I'm excited to take part
in these activities myself one day.
And then I'm definitely going to take
a lot of these lessons to heart.
So, thank you for being generous
with your time
and sharing that with me.
And before we go Arod,
I'd love to ask you
the most important question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Wow. I'd say optimistic,
conservative, and thoughtful.
I love that.
And I think that it's going by,
by what we discussed today
about your different responsibilities,
that's exactly what you're exerting.
So, thank you
for the inspiration for that.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
And best of luck with all these
amazing, amazing communities.
Thank you for having me.
And as everybody says,
it's all about the people.
So, thanks everybody.
Thank you for having me.
And thanks everybody
for being a part of the ride.